all right good afternoon everyone thank
you so much for joining this session
where we're going to talk about
upgrading your. net applications well
first very quickly about me my name is
Olia gavish I have been product manager
at Microsoft for about six years right
now before that I was a net developer
for my entire life and and I'm working
on net modernization I'm also PM for
desktop net stack I'm working on ways
how users can easily attach to Azure and
how they can make their net applications
modern fast performance and so
on so there are different ways how you
can upgrade your applications and the
big one and the one that will give you
so many free uh benefits is upgrading
your net the the platform that your
application is targeting to the latest
version and today I'm going to tell you
everything about why it's good why you
might want to do that and how can you do
that you can also upgrade your mobile
applications if they're built on zaring
forms there is a new offering from
Microsoft called net Maui we'll talk
about that and you can upgrade your
Azure functions you can upgrade uwp to
vinu I3 uh you also can upgrade some
features of your project such as
upgrading file to the latest SDK style
project uh upgrading uh to from on pram
to Asia and so on so let's begin with
upgrading to the latest.net
and before jumping into that I want to
clarify something because I still
receive questions from people like
there's so many different versions of
net there's NET Framework net core there
for uh zarine there is mono there's also
net standard like what should I use how
do they relate to each other why there
are so many yeah that's very valid
question and as you probably know NET
Framework is existed for many many years
that was the first platform that we
created and it was a great and reliable
mature platform for many years but as
technology progresses as modern world uh
gives us more and more requirements for
modern software that framework could no
longer fit all the modern needs of
software applications and that's why few
six seven years ago we created net core
and we buildt it specifically to be
great for web uh Native Cloud
applications and that framework was much
much faster it was completely we did
complete re architecture of the of our
apis of the platform and it's great so
for some time we had NET Framework and
we had net core and we thought that like
net core would be web offering whether
NET Framework would before everything
else as time passed by as we received
the feedback we realized net core is the
way going forward and that is much much
better it allows us to iterate
faster introduce improvements much much
faster so then we based on net core we
got all the best things from that
framework mono zarine and so on and we
created one platform called net we
started with the version. net 5 and many
people thought that's because we wanted
to confuse you guys but actually that
was because five is greater than NET
Framework 4.8 net core 3.1 one so that's
the larger number of all existing net
Frameworks so we want to emphasize
that's the latest net we simplified no
editions just. net and that is the
version of net that you should be using
for to build your
applications it's crossplatform it
allows flexible deployments it has
unparallel performance and it's much
much better in so many different ways we
keep improving net so all our effort all
our changes goes there we're not
changing NET Framework not changing net
core so nothing is happening there it's
still available for you so if you have
your applications they can still run on
those platforms but all the new changes
and improvements they go specifically to
net and you probably notice there is net
standard standing in the shade there
still there why is that well net
standard it's not a framework it's uh a
protocol and we created it for
compatibility so when we had that
situation when we had NET Framework and
net core if you for example were
building your libraries and you wanted
your libraries to be used from both
framework and core you could Target net
standard and net standard ensured that
the
implementations of the apis that you're
using are uh ex exist in NET Framework
and net core so if you target standard
your code is compatible with everything
else now moving forward we will have
just net and net standard is no longer
needed but if you still have some
applications that are targeting NET
Framework and you want compatibility
between those framework and latest net
apps then you can still use net
standard what is else new we switched to
scheduled release
we received the feedback that uh it's
very hard for you to plan your upgrades
when you don't know when we are going to
release the next net version and before
we just released it when we were ready
which was never but at some point we had
to and it was very chaotic so now we're
going to release newnet every November
and every other release will be
long-term support meaning that we
support it for 3 years and every other
release we will just innovate and let
you use the latest apis the latest
features that we have so it's up to you
how you want to upgrade you want to you
can upgrade just once every three years
and switch from long term to long term
you can upgrade every year and get the
latest features that we developed or you
can even upgrade with previews we are
releasing previews almost every month to
let you uh have access to the latest
things that we are working on currently
and provide us
feedback right now we are on Net 7 we
have released it in November 2022 and
very soon net 8 is coming and net 8 will
be another long-term support we'll be
supported for three years so I highly
recommend upgrading toet
8 now why would you want to upgrade well
there are many many reasons
and my favorite one is it's super
performant it also I'm going to just
like quickly talk about everything and
then Deep dive to certain things that
really stand out so it's modern and fast
moving it is crossplatform except V
forms and WPF uh it's open source you
can write much simpler code with the
latest C it has native support for arm
64 uh this platform for was specifically
built for microservices and Cloud native
apps so for those purposes it's much
much better than notet
framework it also has reach ecosystem
and we are making improvements in every
area.net winforms WPF Entity framework
like in every single area there is a
team working on aing performance add in
improvements in the latest
versions and the most important thing
net is the platform going forward as I
mentioned all the changes go only to
net so about performance improvements
there is a huge gap in performance
between NET Framework and net core uh
there's a picture of uh we actually had
a cake in
2016 where we achieved
2,300 per Gap in RPS between framework
and core that was like a huge thing back
then but even since then we keep
improving performance and you can see
that from net to net uh performance RPS
percentage gain still is increasing for
sp. net core here on the picture you can
see a gain compared to core 3.1 so inet
5 6 7 and even in net 8 we're still
growing in this
area and that's not a surprise because
we are working a lot on this area and
here on the graph you can see the number
of PRS that were specifically dedicated
for performance improvements for Net 7
we got over a thousand PRS just for per
and my coworker Steven to is posting
performance improvements in net X every
year so you can see net Corp 1.0 2 3 Net
5 net 6 for Net 7 his article was I
think more than 250 pages so he goes in
all the details of what we have done and
yeah to summarize it for you it's really
really fast the latest.net is the
fastest now if you're curious how that
net compares to other offerings of on
the market ip.net core is 11 times
faster than node GS also faster than
Java
servlet we made improvements in Entity
framework and uh we added distribution
transactions mapping to Json columns for
SQL many others that's in Net 7 and we
made Net 7 four times faster than doet
6 we also added performance specifically
for Vin forms we changed the way how we
redraw controls and you can see the
comparison of exactly same application
targeting NET Framework and targeting
Net
7 so as we made improvements we have
upgraded our own applications and inet 6
that was a long-term support first was
Net 5 regular then net 6 longterm that's
where we upgraded all our apps and you
can see here Microsoft teams asure
active directory Microsoft graphs they
all got a huge CPU decrease and
operational cost decrease and app
efficiency grow significantly so we were
very happy with the result that's why
I'm recommending you to also
upgrade now what else is great I know
you guys love C if you're net developers
so C 11 in introduced lots and lots of
code simplifications and there is even
more improvements in that if C 12 so do
not miss the talk of mat torgenson uh
what's next in C it's going to be
tomorrow in room 11 so definitely check
it
out we've made improvements to net rest
apis so they're minimal you can see just
three lines of code they are power full
we have added new features like map
group API to uh easily scaffold Out full
rest API in the most minimal lines of
code and we have received feedback from
developers and uh made significant
improvements simplification of O so you
can see between net 6 and Net 7 now it's
much much easier basically one line of
code to write it and one line of codee
to call
it here I have a summary of web
development improvements in net8
unfortunately it would take another hour
just to talk about web development
that's not the goal of this talk but you
can see there's a lot of reasons to
upgrade to the latest.net
also native iot inet 7 we reduced
application size on dis and we improved
start
time we also improved WPF and Vin forms
we added new controls one of them is web
view2 that is a successor of web browser
control so it's available as a new G
package you can install it you can use
you can get the benefits of web in your
desktop
application we added another task
another new control task dialogue to Vin
forms and that's the the topic where
people get very surprised that we're
still improving win forms we are there
is a team working on winforms and but
this control specifically we got from
our open- source contributor Constantine
prer that was his suggestion and he
worked with our teams he called to our
API reviews from Germany and like
basically thanks to him we got a new
control in V forms and that is like a
message box on steroids very cool
thing uh we're working on high DPI
issues so with 4K monitors Wind forms
didn't look so good on uh new screens
and you can see in Net 5 everything was
broken in net 6 it looks much much
better and we keep Ting in this
area we added lots of accessibility
improvements for V form specifically we
improve the way how uh assistive
Technologies such as narrator or test
automation are working with the
controls um yeah we added login to in
fors now you can set the ability of
different login levels and like those
are minor things but there are so many
for WPF we introduced lots of tooling
improvements such as Z Life preview
quick actions design time data you can
find it all on the internet in our docs
and there are demos showing
it so like there were just some
highlights of new things in net there is
many many more feel free to Google it
feel free to ask me directly if you have
some particular type of application and
you wonder would that be beneficial for
you to upgrade it you can reach out to
me the default answer is probably yes
unless there are some cases but
now let's talk about how to upgrade your
applications so if your application is
small and easy you can jump to upgrade
process directly but if you're dealing
with a large application uh you probably
want to plenty upgrade first especially
I've got the feedback from developers
very often they want some estimate from
their managers of how much time will it
take how much effort what exactly do we
need to do so specifically for that we
have a tool it's called net upgrade
planner let me show this to to
you so to get this tool you can go to
apis so.net let
me and here would be on the top right
net upgrade planner
once I click it
okay I'm not
sure oh okay I downloaded already but
you'll get the link to download it I
already have it on my machine
so for actually let me start from very
beginning let me call
it
once you launch that net upgrade planner
uh the first uh screen you will see open
project select files select folder uh if
that's your first time uh select files
or select folder if you have already
launched it and you started net upgrade
planner work then you can save the
project and that's what open project
means so open project of net upgrade
planner not not your net project I'm
going to do select folder I have some
sample app
here so right now what is happening it
gets all the Nate apis from our server
and it looks through the dependencies
through usage of net apis in your
application and it shows you first it
shows you the graph of your app and I
find it very helpful so I can click I
can navigate to this specific node go
back on the top left I can see all the
assemblies that's my assemblies and
assemblies that I am referencing in my
application I can see current framework
I can set desired framework so right now
it's set toet 8 but I can do set desired
framework and choose whatever I want
want standard for
example then I can specify platform so I
can say for example I'm developing only
for Windows so do not if I have some
incompatibilities like some apis are not
implemented on Android iOS that's okay
I'm building only for
Windows um this is the portability score
so for some applications it's 100% for
some it's less and number of problems
and I can you know to analyze I'm going
to first thing that I'm going to do I'm
going to remove everything that is not
my own code because for the NIT that's
probably a newer version of nit that I
can go ahead and download and then I
will be compatible of course something
that you need to check
but most likely
so I'm going to remove everything except
my eShop three
projects and now I can see issues and
warning it specifically for my project
let me know if you cannot see I can
probably zoom
in but here I have API is not available
on all platforms so that's something
that if I'm building just for Windows
that's probably fine remoting not
available in net
core unres reference and so
on uh there is also way of exporting
those uh results sharing it with your
co-workers with your
management
so yeah going back to our slide
deck
awesome all right once you assessed how
much work it's going to be or what
exactly you need to change you can move
to migrating your application
specifically and for that we have
another tool that is called net Upgrade
Assistant so it supports upgrades from
NET Framework from net core and from
earlier versions of net
5678 two current long-term support short
standard term support and
preview it it supports various types of
net applications we tried to build it
for basically everything that has
implementation in the latest.net we
supported it for Upgrade Assistant and
it has two flavors there is vs extension
and also there's C C tool depending on
what you prefer to use to get more
information about it you can go to
aka.ms uh net. net Upgrade
Assistant
and let me show you the site
first so this is the website you will
see if you get uh through that link uh
there is a short video on how to use
visual Studio extension there is a
instructions on CLI Tool uh and more
information
and with that let's go to visual studio
and um I show you upgrade the system
connection so for example this is a VIN
forms short demo application right now
it's
targeting NET Framework 4.8
I'm going to upgrade it to the
latest.net with Upgrade Assistant
Upgrade Assistant here I'll show you how
to use Visual Studio extension first to
install
it you search for net Upgrade Assistant
this
guy I already have it on my machine so
once you get it on your machine on right
click on your project file in solution
Explorer you will see this option
upgrade and once I click on it it will
start Upgrade Assistant the first option
and this Upgrade Assistant analyzes your
application it shows you only steps that
are uh available for your app so if you
see something different that means that
for your specific app those steps don't
make
sense two options here first is upgrade
project feature Fe and upgrade project
to new net version I'll show you net
version and at the end of this
presentation I'll show you how you can
upgrade your
features so there are two options for
desktop uh applications for Vin forms
and WPF upgrading project in place and
side by side in place Upgrade Assistant
is going to just take my app and move it
to the latest.net side by side it will
leave my application as is it will
create create a copy and upgrade a copy
depends on what you prefer I'm risky
like that I'm going to do in
place now uh options what I want to
upgrade to as I mentioned there are
three options first is long-term support
currently it's net 6 in November it's
going to be net 8 then it's standard
term support currently Net 7 and there's
an option to upgrade to the latest
preview depending on what your
application is targeting it will uh
offer only upgrade forward so you cannot
upgrade from net 8 to net 6 but if
you're on net 8 preview one it will let
you upgrade to the latest preview
preview 6 preview
s so I'm going to use
net8 here on this step I can select or
unselect the components that I want to
upgrade by default Upgrade Assistant
will suggest me what is needed in my
case it's everything I'm going to leave
it as is and click upgrade
selection while it's working have any of
you guys uh used Upgrade Assistant
already raise a hand if you have oh nice
one hand awesome did it work for
you
okay awesome all right well for me it
worked surprise
surprise and uh here you can
see let me Zoom here so there's some
solid uh green checkboxes that means
that upgrade the assistant modified this
file there is unfilled green checkbox
means that my file was compatible as
this upgrade the system did nothing but
everything is good there's also some
warnings for warning I'm going to open
it and read what it says and it says
default font in win forms has been
changed from this one from from that one
to this one in order to change the
default font use apis so now as I
upgraded my application my default font
is different if my UI was specifically
designed for previous font I can do that
I can click click learn more and go
ahead and read how I can set the default
font for all applications everywhere to
the previous
one other than that everything
succeeded I can also see
detailed uh description of what was
happening in the output folder that logs
every
step and now if I go to
properties I I can see that my
application is targeting net
8 so in my case uh it took me almost no
time to upgrade from NET Framework toet
8 for desktop applications wi forms WPF
for class libraries for console
applications it usually should be very
straightforward let
me
there still might be breaking changes
and we log all those breaking changes so
you can go ahead and read about them at
docs
microsoft.com doet core compatibility
and then uh there is a breaking changes
for every version of net but uh the
hardest part in the upgrade would be
moving from NET Framework to net Core
Family Once you got on net core or any
net then upgrade should be easy and we
do not expect your application to be
broken it should be very fast and
straightforward all right now we talked
about V forms WPF exactly same uh very
easy should just work uh about libraries
when you're upgrading libraries what
should you target as I mentioned before
when I was talking about net St
standard if your applications if you're
using only net
678 you do not need net standard you can
just upgrade your library to net same
version
678 but if your library used by both NET
Framework and net apps then you want to
use net standard and you want to use 2.0
we also have net standard 2.1 but that
one has some apis that are not supported
in NET Framework so for compatibility
reasons use net standard
2.0 and if you want to benefit from both
the reach uh of like NET Framework and
net uh latest. net and you also want to
get the latest features that are
implemented only on latest.net 678 then
you can m
multitarget you can read more on this
blog post about net standard and its
future and meanwhile um another question
that I got asked is once you upgraded to
net core or Net 5 then you can very
easily upgrade just go in Visual Studio
properties and then in Target framework
in combo box just choose
different uh Target framework so the
question is should I still use Upgrade
Assistant if I'm for example moving from
Net 5 to net 6 or not what do you guys
think well I would recommend using
Upgrade Assistant because we have
implemented uh some fixes for breaking
changes and some uh notifications like
your sofware V forms so Upgrade
Assistant will give you better
experience it will try to make your code
compatible not just change Target
framework attribute in your project file
but also modify your code to make it
work so use Upgrade
Assistant now let's talk about upgrading
web
applications uh first again to clarify
there's another confusion Point uh that
there's sp. net and sp. net core and
sometimes when people are talking about
latest net such as net 6 they still you
say isp. net core well initial web
framework was called asp.net and then
the new generation we called it sp. net
core and it still has that name the uh
sp. net that we are using for net 6 7
and 8 it's still sp. net core same
framework so when we're talking about
core or net
5678 it's sp. net core if you hear that
don't be confused it's just probably we
will remove that core from.net
eventually as well but right now it is
what it
is now for sp. net the situation is
slightly different uh it requires
usually significant code changes because
there is a huge difference between net
sp. net and sp. net core so there is new
up startup model configuration and so on
and for this one you can use Upgrade
Assistant but Upgrade Assistant does
slightly different things and usually uh
in experience of my users when they're
upgrading web applications it takes them
much longer time uh more effort and they
prefer the different approach to upgrade
if for net uh for desktop class
libraries uh
console applications you could just run
upgrade the system then be done maybe in
a day for web applications sometimes
it's weeks sometimes it's months so here
we use the Strangler fig pattern and
there is a thing there is that Strangler
fig that grows around the tree and
eventually it covers the entire tree and
it kills the tree inside and only the
Fig
remains same uh way works the pattern so
it introduces the facade uh in front of
Legacy code and we start creating a
modern code that duplicates Legacy
functionality then as we progress with
our migration Legacy Cod reduces modern
con grows and at the end only modern
cord stays or in other words when we are
looking at web application there is
external traffic there's sp. net
application and business logic that's
how my app looks like then when I start
upgrading I put as.net core application
as a facade and I'm using yarp proxy to
talk to
my.net application and there is also
business logic so external traffic goes
to my core app then uh for everything
that is not implemented it goes to my
old app and uh for everything that is
already implemented in core it executes
new core code eventually I move my views
classes everything to new code and only
new code is getting executed there is
nothing to be done foret framework
application and then we can get rid of
NET Framework
application it's it's done with yarp so
yarp it's yet another reverse
proxy it's uh customizable proxy
functionality supports sp. net course
3.1 and later uh it's available as new
git package and we use it for our
applications as
well and oh another thing that was on
this
picture was adapters so probably my
business logic is using
system.web system.web does not exist in
net CORE family so for that we created a
system. web adapters and they cover HTTP
context everything that is on the screen
it's available as a new git package if
you're using Upgrade Assistant it will
automatically use this those adapters so
you don't need to worry about it
everything will be done automatically
for you all right let's go to visual
studio again
and here I have my web
application let me also make
sure it is
targeting NET Framework
4.8 I'm going to upgrade it to the
latest.net so right click upgrade
upgrade project to newer framework so
here you might notice before I had
options side by side and um in place
here I have one option side by side
incremental for web project that's the
way we suggest to use for upgrades and
that is the way that is using Strangler
F pattern that I was talking about so
I'm going to use that next question if I
already have started migration
I and I already created new net 678
project I can specify existing project
uh in another case I want uh upgrade
system to create this new project for
me so I'm going
to call it
net8 I probably done it before so I
already have that folder all right same
question here which. net
net8 so here the first step is that yarp
is creating a facade so right now my
code will not be migrated what is going
to happen right now I will get a new.
net8 application
here right next to my original
app and if you compare it has basic.net
like template files but it does not have
any of my controllers models nothing
like that so right now it's just empty
but the infrastructure is already
working so when I run it this new. net8
application will run it has no
implementation for my uh any end points
so when I call my app it will forward uh
execution to The old. NET Framework app
and now I can start migrating my parts
of the framework application piece by
piece the way I'm going to do it same
upgrade done here okay so here I have a
little
summary in my project I have 20 end
points they all are on NET Framework and
nothing is on net yet and I have options
to upgrade controller upgrade class
upgrade view so I'm going to click
upgrade
controller I will pick controllers like
any account controller click
upgrade upgrade the system suggests me
to upgrade everything that depends uh
that my controller depends on as well
so I'm going to click
upgrade and Upgrade Assistant is going
to work on 53
files so that way um a lot of asks from
web developers we received about like I
cannot just stop my application and work
on upgrade on modernization to the
latest.net right I need to maintain my
app I need to introduce features there
are people that are work working on new
functionality so they wanted to do it in
parallel and that's exactly how this
model works so your application works
simly in production it just when you
intro when you migrate the new piece it
starts executing the new uh core. Net 5
678 but for everything else it uses NET
Framework and it still should
work all right something
has happened here and here's another
great thing that I love to use is oh
first let's let's look at summary okay
so
now I have three end points migrated and
17 left on the old NET Framework and in
end point Explorer I can see what is
implemented in my net 8 application what
is still um no that's everything my
original app has all the endpoints so
whenever my application is getting
called like account log off it's going
to execute the new8 code when it's
called Uh when I call something that is
not here it will execute The NET
Framework so just like that one by one
you're moving your controllers views Etc
until you have everything on the
latest.net it is a more involved
process but people who did that said
that they were very happy with the
result so hopefully you will be too I
mean you definitely will be but you will
have to struggle through
upgrades all right now let's talk about
upgrading your mobile applications do
you any of you have Zarin forms
apps awesome we have some
hands yes so for ex in forms we have a
new offering called net Maui have you
guys tried net Maui
already okay oh yeah but we have
different hands nice nice yes net Mai
it's a new way of building mobile and
desktop applications so with one code
you can have your app running on Windows
ma OS IOS and Android and it's all uh
UniFi . net uh you can build mobile
desktop hybrid
applications uh it uses benefits of
Native apis Native
performance uh there are reason so
usually I'm getting asked why would I
want to move from zamary inet Maui and
the very big reason is because Zary is
supported until May
2022 20124 and then uh it's Maui so
there is still some time to do your
migration but I would already start
thinking or doing it but also there that
was a stick now a carrot uh there is
lots of great things in Mau new things
that we introduced uh since zarine and
there is uni. net you can take advantage
of common Innovations in project system
CI experience hot reload latest
TP uhet ma supports multiv window uh
because it was built for mobile and
desktop we made improvements to make it
good experience for desktop so multi-
window is one of them there's also we
support like right click events layouts
uh that is coming net8 so that's on my
second
slide there's also rebuild layouts
single project one project for all
applications so now in zarine you had uh
your project iOS Android and so on so on
now you have one project and specific
things for platforms are in separate
folders you probably can so many more
things for the sake of saving the time
what's coming to net 8 in Maui we have
improved like we fixed lots and lots of
issues because in the beginning Maui was
like the Prototype then Early times and
and since then we make it made it way
more stable introduced net workloads new
get packages for
previews we made a better experience for
desktop in net 8 we added tool tips for
every control context menu rightclick
events and so on also there is a way of
building hybrid applications with Blazer
and Maui and we added deep Link in for
Blazer hybrid hybrid web view um so
that's another option how you can build
your apps and uh it's smaller and faster
apps with 9 iot as I said before we
introduced lots of improvements to um
Native iot
apis all right actually let
me very quickly show you basically the
experience for upgrading Maui is very
similar
and also you
can use Upgrade
Assistant and I have a my up
here let me see what it's
targeting
yeah okay
great so right click
upgrade in place or side by
side net 8 very similar experience
upgrade selection it's going to upgrade
my project file then I'm going to
upgrade my Android iOS this is a
slightly longer Adventure so probably to
save some
time we can okay it's
happening anyways everything that you
have seen before and we just released a
new version where you can if if you
prefer manual upgrades you can drag your
files uh your zmer forms files into Mai
project and you will get a light b bulp
in a code editor suggesting to make it
Maui files so make fixes to your files
to make it compatible with
Maui all right the next topic Azure
functions uh does any of you uh work
with aure function
functions awesome in that case we're
going to show that so for that I'm going
to create a new aure functions
project
and
see aure
functions
so here I'm going to choose NET
Framework V1 so that's the oldest
version asure functions V want targeting
NET Framework again let's make sure it
does Net Framework 4.1
here right so four Azure
functions very similar experience right
click upgrade in place upgrade choosing
net selecting un selecting I recommend
to keep it all and what is going to
happen here it will upgrade my target
framework to net 8 but also it will
upgrade aure functions from V1 or V2 or
V3 to V4 the latest
version all right so now let's me look
at the project file here you can see I
forgot to show you that
before it was aure functions but you can
trust me it was V1 and now it's V4 and
also Target framework got upgraded as
well
awesome all
right
[Music]
so uh I'm going to show you also how to
upgrade some features of my project for
that let me create class Library
targeting NET
Framework and that is an empty class
library but if I look at the project
file
here
unload you can see that's the project
file of completely empty very basic
class Library it's still lots and lots
of
text in net core and latest.net we have
introduced a new uh format for project
file that is called SDK style so when
you're upgrading to the latest.net your
project file is automatically upgraded
to the SDK style and that was happening
behind the scenes for all my demos but
we received feedback that some people
prefer to just get that upgrade of the
project file without changing net TFM
and for that we created this feature
also edited to Upgrade Assistant and
that is that second option upgrade
project
features so right now there's only one
project feature SDK style but we're
going to add more there and if you have
some suggestions or some urgent needs
for your applications what has to happen
please let us know the best way to let
us know is here in Visual Studio send
feedback suggest the feature
and go ahead and create the ticket we
are read through every ticket there and
that's how we prioritize our work so if
you're if you create the feature and if
some other people like it that will be
very high on our road map okay convert
to project file to
SDK the converters are running that is
very simple very fast but now when I
look to my project file instead of that
huge XML it's just a few lines of code
so that's another feature that you can
upgrade for your project with upgrade
assistent of course I recommend to
upgrade the entire thing to the
latest.net but if you need just this
change that's how you can get it
done
and because we're close on
time I'm going to leave a few minutes
for questions and just to summarize for
you you can upgrade your any
applications and here's the
recommendation what you should upgrade
to for each type so for V firms in WPF
upgrade to net 6 7 and 8 preview where
eight will be uh long-term support
General availability in November for uwp
you can upgrade to Vin ui3 uh you can
also stay where you are depending on
what you prefer for sumary inform forms
definitely recommending upgrading to net
Maui uh you can upgrade your WCF
applications to net 67 with core WCF
that's uh a new package it's a our
project that we created in Microsoft
with Microsoft Engineers created it for
that one right now we don't have a
support in uh Visual Studio extension
so you need to use CLI all the version
but if you go to docs it will guide you
through which version you need to
install how to upgrade everything is
easy and straightforward and that's
something that is on our backlog we're
going to edit soon class libraries net
standard or net 6 7 or 8 or multitarget
SP sp. net top.net core on net 678 and
aure functions upgrade to the latest net
and latest version
before with that any questions are very
welcome
yes web forms that's a great question no
unfortunately web forms are not
supported and that's something that
we've been looking at the feedback and
uh thinking a lot about it but uh as
Microsoft we consider it old Tech and
we're keeping it the way is we're not
moving it to latest.net
that being said there is an offering
from some third party company they offer
some upgrades but that's not by
Microsoft and we don't have to do
anything with that but you can try it if
you have a need to upgrade to latest.net
but also you know from talking to
webforms developers they usually not
very motivated to change their apps they
say like this is my app it's just
running in production I'm not touching
it it's just the way it is I'm not going
to do anything for that and I'm building
new applications with different
stack more questions
yes so that would be better question for
our zmer in PMS which is med monila and
David or now as far as I know but I
might be slightly wrong about it that we
got some apis in net and the uh zarine
Android zarine iOS should stay you can
use them as is but we're not going to
add any new things
there and yeah zarine forms there is a
straight path to net
Mai
yes
yeah uh which version were
you okay so the question just to repeat
in the Microsoft uh in the
microphone
uh mentioned that they looked at the uh
upgrading uh Base Class library right
the class library to the latest to net
but some features were not present there
in net so has then been been updated or
not try. net 8 Pro a lot of things are
implemented in net 8 if you looked at
net core early versions like net core
1.0 was very tiny and had very very
little features then in net core 2.0 2.1
we added about 20,000 apis then we kept
Aden so the best way to try the latest.
net and if something is not implemented
then most likely it's by Design so if
it's web forms let me actually have a
slide for that so unsupported features
up domains remoting web
forms everything so if that's something
in this list it's not going to be
implemented but everything else should
be there
yes oh that is another great question
that I forgot to cover so visual studio
extension is just for visual studio but
CLI is available for Mach as
well yeah more
questions
yes uh is that net uh Upgrade Assistant
have net versions right is that the
question
so no but if you uh it has all the
latest versions and if you don't have
net version installed on your machine it
will tell you you need to install it and
here's the link so should be very
easy yeah more
questions all right if that's it thank
you so much for your
[Applause]
time